what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch Brooklyn
nine nine today something episode 99 oh
episode 999 okay whatever yeah uh leave
a like on this video that would mean a
lot subscribe click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction for
the next episode but nine is up you know
about our patreon we don't need to tell
you about it alrighty let's get to it
efforts four years ago on this exact date you
told me I was too old to learn how to do the worm
[Music]
oh God damn
as I was telling the squad our old CEO
Captain McGinley just passed away oh no
I'll have the travel details later hey is anyone
nourishing flat out embarrassing sad day it's
crazy how different things were when McGinley
was Captain it's like the wild west oh yeah we had
some fun I didn't and every one of those photos I
look up tight and worry whoa Jake am I too high
strung I wouldn't say you're too high strung
you just are high strung you know you're strong
is what makes you strong you're strong strongly
so where's the party at trick question the party's
right here boy oh funerals are a meat market
sadness is a powerful aphrodisiac no it's not and
how come everyone cries during sex commissioner is
retiring next year they put a short list together
a possible Replacements and you're on it this is
your first interview really damn dude what's
going on is Captain Holt has an interview to
become the commissioner of the freaking NYPD who
says I'm even interested in becoming commissioner
you constantly including the first day I met you
I'm interested in becoming commissioner good to
know whoa wow that was real please calm down right
totally don't want to jinx it I don't believe in
jinxes great then you won't mind me saying it's
a lock you're definitely going to get it you're
going to spell even better with that Lord High
commander of all Justice tank on you let's do this
this route is more direct no okay you do you
Commish please don't call me then okay fine I'll
just call you the Mish no wait Missy Elliott no
wait Mrs doubt fire oh my God what is it nakatomi
Plaza oh the building from Die Hard can we go in
can we pay our specs we'll have flight leads in
three and a half hours and but it's like what is
time even Legalize It pull it over there Argyle of
course what's the name of the driver in the movie
we're going to Dr Tony Plaza there's gonna be role
play it's even more beautiful than I imagined it's
an empty floor that's under construction just like
in the movie This is the floor that John McLean
ran on with his bare feet take my picture with it
it's a good one that's a good one that's a good
one that's a good one okay all 600 of these are
great we should probably head to the airport all
right let's get out of here are you are you sure
about that the door is locked that's strange I
thought the guard propped it open I kicked my
way out but I think these windows are bulletproof
we're not getting any reception in here kick the
door open all right everybody just calm down I'm
sure that guard will be back in like five minutes
we're gonna miss our flight I should be
sitting next to a semi-famous person that
I can't quite place right now come on which one
you guys okay up here yes see I told you not to
give up hope it's a miracle we're still gonna
make it yeah we missed our flight by a lot oh
what is going on there are human storms in the
midwest all flights are grounded oh man but at
least you're not gonna crash in a storm now we
have until Monday morning and it takes 48 hours
to drive from LA to New York we've still got time
no we don't well there are no available Vehicles
I'm just gonna have to call the commissioner
cancel this meeting no not on my watch we just
have to think there's got to be a way to get you
back commandeer a vehicle got it may I present
to you the finest RV that not much money can
buy the American creeper let's get creeping
let's do this they're already in Los Angeles
are they leaving Los Angeles they're going
from yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah that's
where the nakatoi plus yes now I had to take a
second too so what are you gonna do when you're
coming your Commish I think you should focus on
interagency communication and Intel sharing
also laser channels well I'd like to see an
increase in vacation days and we should all get
Summers off like teachers let the city go to purge
Dallas the hell we're supposed to be in Louisiana
by now speedometer's broken no wonder everyone was
flipping us off I thought it was just racism
well I'm sure it didn't help yeah I'm sorry I
don't think we can make it with time I feel like
he doesn't want to make it uh from now on we use
the bathroom in the RV no so many of us I know
I'm sorry but it's the only way me first [Music]
you guys didn't hear that dude
I'm still hearing it laughs
I'm not comfortable operating this vehicle at
a speed greater than the prevailing Road in
traffic conditions fine I'll do it myself this is
going great oh man I definitely Smell Smoke pull
over right now I checked everywhere nothing's on
fire nothing's even smoldering we just wasted 10
minutes for no reason oh we have to focus and
think of a new plan for getting hold back for
his interview well perhaps we should just focus
on finding a place to sleep tonight how far is
it to Mansford Texas like half an hour great I
have cousins there there's a boil in every state
oh geez Tommy Becca Becca is a man oh thank you
so much for letting us stay here Galen Howard I'd
much rather be hanging out with you what are you
doing boys bringing you some water thanks so uh
are you talking to is that your mystery hunk babe
oh yeah I'm dating a woman I'm bi oh that's great
Rose I just want you to know that I totally want
to talk about it right now okay just leave it
alone it's not very Christian of her no I know you
always hope that you'd be commissioner no over the
course of my career I've learned that it's best
not to have hopes it's like saying it's best
not to have dreams I only have one dream a year
always on tax day in it I must file an extension
thank you for trying the deep down I always knew
I'd never be commissioner all my dreams start
with my step-sister painting her house and and
the house looking great oh sex yep you knew it
there's a huge fulfillment center there there is
yes Charles I called them and they shipped their
packages out of a regional airport they do that's
too much maybe back off a little bit the point
is we get to fly in the back of a cargo plane to
Philadelphia but we've been in these close since
Friday we smell like butt I guess we'll just
have to borrow some from who yeah killing it
sleep the Brooklyn yeah we look so cool right now
I feel like we're in a mervin's commercial I'm
yep yeah it's terrifying but it doesn't
matter because we're almost to the airport
like illegals we got a tip saying there were
drugs being moved in the back of a gray never
mind this is a bovine berothel who called this
tip in it's impossible to say they said the
drugs are in the back of a bovine transport unit
who calls it that everyone that's what they're
called huh damn and you were the only robot I
know sir bovine transport unit meet more zeep
let me see your phone I want to see your call
history no let me see it oh damn 25 minutes
ago outgoing call to 9-1-1 you sabotaged us Mr
Robot you call the pigs on us the pigs you drove
by nakatomi Plaza on purpose didn't you and then
you trapped Us in there didn't you fine I did over
here is the elevator when the claims left and now
I'm uh take my picture with it there were plenty
of rental cars at the airport weren't there
[Laughter] blow up the creeper not on purpose
ouch I realized you're revolting cheese puffs
were made with some extremely unstable chemicals
I deposited a few in the gas tank I thought they'd
shut the engine down I didn't realize they ignited
I made a decision a while ago and now some
people are holding it over my head oh yeah
as well I was wondering if that would
ever come back Seamus Murphy the gangster
he offered me info that would get you
and Rosa out of prison in exchange for
a favor oh my God you did all of this
for us I love you dabbed in dapped him
the first thing that you taught me when you
came to the 99 is that we're a team so your
responsibility is my responsibility too
in mine and mine and mine and mine and my
ax Oh Captain My Captain remember that
time we went to the deli for cold cuts
and the ticket machine was broken so you
found out what time everyone arrived and
made them getting a single file line
from earliest to latest yeah higher
you might want to stand back for this sir it can
get pretty intense oh our Union Health Plan has
100 reimbursement for out-of-state ambulance
rights Scully will fake a medical emergency
don't need to fake it always having at least
one ambulance can drive 25 miles over the posted
speed limit so we'll get there by 9 pm there's
a small airport there but thanks to a loophole
in HR 377551 we will land on an airstrip outside
of Finksburg Maryland we take a cab to Baltimore
jump on the 6 40 a.m train to New York arriving
at 9 26. Kevin will meet us at Penn Station with
a fresh Captain's uniform from there it's a 29
minute cab ride to One Police Plaza you change
on the way we should get to your meeting in five
minutes to spare please that was a monologue
also bovine brothel name me your
sex tape [Music] are you working
Peralta thank you for not
quitting on me it was all him yep
I know how important this is to you you know what
really makes a trip first class here we don't
really have time for a speech right now you're
fine your breath sucks just pop it and go [Music]
drink this instead a mimosa oh I'm sorry
so nosy actually felt really good to tell
somebody on the squad finally I'm glad it was you
all right my head is in the ring for commissioner
I still don't know how we're gonna deal with the
Murphy complication laser jails
but you know we'll figure it out
there's always that very particular pronunciation
that was fun that was fun wow Rose is bisexual
changes everything so hot that's right man it's
for it's for us but if a guy is bi it means he's
just gay yeah that's true right less of a man yeah
yeah they're just the gay guys yeah they're trying
to be cool by liking chicks too but now there's
gay but women can be bisexual but I encourage
all women to be bisexual [__] I think all
of them are yeah that's what that's what the
internet's taught me that's right man it's good
for women to be gay it's unacceptable for me
tomato potato you know balls
um no good for her I mean that's fun that's
awesome that's fun shirts she's a hot girl
I wonder who the guest star will be oh
yeah let's take bets uh Millie Bobby
Brown sure especially whatever this
was made definitely the right time
uh oh goodness [__] Spacek definitely [__]
Spacek I'm going Halle Berry dating no no no
no she made out with Adrian Brody in front of her
husband on stage at the Oscars she's not gay nope
or can she play a game no she can't stop possible
she can't imagine what it would be like I don't
know who uh it'll be uh Erica Ferreira it'll be
Gina Gershon and Jennifer Tilly oh I love it both
um no that's good man that's good she uh
she'd be a great bisexual lover I'd imagine
makes sense uh that's fun but now this is uh this
is a fun this is a real road trip episode it's
truly a road trip episode and the fact that it had
such good crunch time about it a lot of times road
trip comedies can feel stretched out like the
movies so the fact that this is only like a 20
minute show forces them to really condense stuff
and they use it to great effect I thought it was
really well written and I thought you know having
the motif of how much time is left on it gives
a good ticking time clock to it and the reveals
that it came out like I even love the revealing
I love the way that reveal came out man we knew
there were what it was but it's been so long I
forgot about it that for it to come to the service
I was like oh that's why he sabotages I don't even
think about that yeah and that's a great like
additional layer because like you know it's
one of those things you can get an inkling for
of like oh maybe he doesn't want this for some
reason or yeah his heart's not in it but yeah
it's not that it's a great opportunity because
it was like a couple episodes ago or something I
was like wait a minute though there's that whole
thing where they made the deal and The Leverage
yeah and yeah and then I completely forgot and I
and I love the long game of that especially on
a show like this you know it's mostly episodic
yeah they work their serial elements very nicely
throughout this and I thought the road trip bits
were actually really funny yeah nakatomi Plaza
was a great the way the way that they they still
built uh like a twists and turns around uh all
the sabotaging was really well done too planting
all these seeds and then when hold was revealing
all of it that was really well constructed some of
that should have been like the nakatomi plaza one
you should be able to see that coming oh yeah yeah
it's just like such a such a like a coincidence
such a perfect yeah strike because there was
there's such an agreement thing to him and when
he said we have more time if you want to take more
photos and there's such an agreeable thing when
he said that I was like this is that a character
it seems like you should be in a hurry to get to
the airport regardless but Andre power was given
like the perfect performance for this and I loved
all the boils too that was a really funny bit they
just had some really funny hi cheeks that were
happening here it was really funny I love to like
go to the bathroom and Terry being traumatized
that was hilarious RV blowing up because of the
cheese puffs and like Amy being chill is not that
funny but the fact that she got a fully unleash
at the end and reach her maximum potential right
yeah totally that was excellent that was a really
fun episode yeah I liked a lot I feel very warm
inside and yeah I like that resolution of like
you know don't let this I mean it's a dangerous
Choice sure but also yeah I mean like you know
go Live Your Dream and and we'll figure
the rest out in real time as it comes as
it happens yeah yeah that family support feels
like it's been well earned over this time yeah
yeah and just yeah I don't know I think you're
absolutely right it's like it's got all the
benefits of a road trip thing without doing the
requisite part of a lot of road trip movies where
it really feels like you've just been in the car
a long time yeah yeah it's like you get to bypass
that one element that can sometimes drag these
things down and uh yeah it doesn't get bogged
down by that just stick to the snappy energy
yeah and make use of the nakatobia building on
whatever lot that building's on alrighty guys for
Brooklyn nine nine another episode Down how many
are in this season 20 some odd and then we call it
a week after that yeah take a breather and still
know Gina still know Gina she would have held
this episode back despite so much she would have
uh ruined everything not missing her it's kind
of a weird sign it is strange I mean I'm curious
what it'll be like when she comes back but that's
probably like oh I missed her yeah sure it'll be
it'll be that it'll be like I'm glad to have her
back but also I haven't I would be lying if I've
said like these episodes have felt like anything
was missing yeah which I feel bad about because uh
because there are so I remember Gina was was like
the slowest character for us to get on board with
but has had some like Hilarious Moments uh but
at the same time she often seems to be weaving
between plots yeah I don't know I don't know I
was curious we'll see when they bring her back
all right guys well leave your thoughts down below
tell us your nitpicks we'll talk with you all soon